verschärfte coroner regeln wie bund und
länder die steigende zahl der
infektionen in den griff bekommen wollen
keine sorge vor engpässen für die
grippesaison gibt es genug impfdosen
versichern der gesundheitsminister und
apotheker innen weniger gift im alltag
die eu will gefährliche chemikalien aus
plastikflaschen kleidung oder kosmetik
verbannen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am mittwoch auch
sport gibt's wieder mitten arbeitnehmern
ein schwimmender familie seit 14 uhr
sitzen sie zusammen bundeskanzlerin und
ministerpräsidentinnen und präsidenten
zum ersten mal seit langer zeit wieder
leibhaftig was wohl der komplexität der
aufgabe geschuldet ist die lautet eine
gemeinsame corona strategie zu
entwickeln
die bundesweit bestand hat und vor allem
von der bevölkerung auch akzeptiert wird
die bundesregierung ist unter anderem
mit der forderung in die verhandlungen
gegangen eine neue warnstufe einzuführen
schon bei 35 infizierten pro 100000
einwohnern in sieben tagen sollen die
maßnahmen verschärft werden das betreffe
derzeit mehr als 50 kommunen unter
anderem mit einer strengeren masken
pflicht einer sperrstunde und weniger
teilnehmern bei veranstaltungen andreas
köhlers berichtet die einladung nach
berlin war überfällig oder überflüssig
je nach eingeladenen mit den 16
ministerpräsidenten fahren vom
kanzleramt 16 meinungen vor
bayerns markus söder der ein
bundeseinheitliches vorgehen will
schleswig-holsteins daniel günther der
den vorwurf der kleinstaaterei für
dümmliches gerede hält die kritik am
streit der bundesländer zunehmend
genervt im ergebnis schafft es nur eine
ungleichheit in deutschland eine unruhe
wir können es den menschen nicht
erklären
und es ist ein wirklich unerträglicher
zustand wenn drei vier fünf
ministerpräsidenten mit
unterschiedlichen botschaften der hand
werfen wir der kanzlerin nach außen
geben
das dürfte die kanzlerin ähnlich sehen
in der bundesregierung herrscht frust
vor allem der streit um das sogenannte
beherbergungs verbot löse
akzeptanzprobleme aus warnt der
gesundheitsminister es geht ja nicht
darum die infektionszahlen irgendwie
runterzubringen um sie unterzubringen
sondern wir wollen damit unsere freiheit
zurück gewinnen wir wollen weihnachten
für und mit der familie möglich machen
wir wollen insgesamt eben mit möglichst
wenig beschränkungen
auch in die nächsten wochen und monate
gehen können massive beschränkungen
treten bisher bei mehr als 50
infizierten in kraft pro 100000
einwohner in sieben tagen in zukunft
dürften schon 35 reichen dann müssen
private feierlichkeiten eingeschränkt
werden
ich glaube da sind sich alle einig dass
man dann reagieren muss private feiern
einschränken eine sperrstunde vielleicht
alkoholverbote die opposition sagt nicht
grundsätzlich nein aber wenn eine
familie aus berlin im schwarzwald urlaub
machen will dann ist das für die
pandemie keine gefahr erst recht nicht
wenn auf hygiene und abstand geachtet
wird so heftig der streit über den kurs
so unumstritten das ziel einen zweiten
lockdown verhindern
die angekündigte pressekonferenz hat
noch nicht angefangen woran liegts theo
koll ist das gespräch im kanzleramt so
kompliziert ja die zeichen standen von
anfang an auf harte diskussionen denn
die meinungen und die lagen in den
ländern sind einfach zu unterschiedlich
vor allem bei einem so genannten
beherbergungs verbot hätten die haltung
ja nicht unterschiedlicher sein können
vielleicht hat die hausherrin auch
deshalb heute ganz bewusst den führenden
immunologen zu einem vortrag eingeladen
der den versammelten
ministerpräsidentinnen bescheinigte
es sei nicht fünf vor zwölf sondern sei
schon 12 und er hat zu einem
ausreiseverbot für menschen aus
risikogebieten geraten
diese wissenschaftliche waren glocke hat
dann so ist zu hören zu einer
anderthalbstündigen diskussion geführt
und die konkreten politischen
verhandlungen haben deshalb erst
deutlich später begonnen
sie erwähnten gerade schon den größten
knackpunkt nämlich die sozusagen das
beherbergungs verbot oder auch die
verordnete testpflicht bei reisen im in
deutschland wie ist es ist man daher
weiter gekommen was hören sie also das
würde mich sehr wundern auch weil sich
die ministerpräsidenten im vorfeld noch
einmal gegeneinander positioniert hatten
das müsste heute schon die quadratur des
kreises sein was man aber offensichtlich
vorbereitet sind andere einheitliche
maßnahmen also beispielsweise eine
ergänzende masken pflicht eine
sperrstunde für die gastronomie da ist
23 uhr im gespräch und eine teilnehmer
begrenzt
song für private feiern auch da sind
zehn personen im gespräch und zwar schon
ab dem sogenannten inzidenz wert von 35
und nicht erst ab 50 neuinfektionen auf
100.000 einwohner wie das im moment der
fall ist sollte trotz dieser maßnahmen
der anstieg der infektion innerhalb von
zehn tagen nicht zum stillstand kommen
dann sollen weitere einschränkungen
folgen wie beispielsweise eine weitere
verringerung in der zahl von menschen
die man im öffentlichen raum treffen
darf
bis hierhin erstmal vielen dank theo sie
bleiben für uns am ball
falls ich noch was ergibt während der
sendung schalten wir noch mal zu ihnen
nach berlin schauen wir erst noch mal
auf die aktuellen corona zahlen
das robert koch institut meldet den
höchsten stand seit mitte april 5132
neuinfektionen auch der sieben tage
trend zeigt nach oben
so haben sich im durchschnitt täglich
4310 menschen neu angesteckt gestern lag
der wert noch bei 4 1030 und die zahl
der an und mit dem virus verstorben ist
sprunghaft gestiegen von 13 auf jetzt
tagesaktuell 43 tel
die gesamtzahl erhöht sich damit auf
9677 die zahlen steigen und damit
wachsen wege sehen auch die sorgen wie
sieht es bei den gesundheitsämtern aus
die ein etc
eine zentrale rolle dabei spielen zu
verhindern dass sich das virus
ausbreitet über die lage in den kliniken
und in den teststationen berichtet und
wann cushing schlange stehen an der
korona teststation am kölner
hauptbahnhof viele lassen sich hier
testen obwohl sie kerngesund sind der
grund ist ein anderer
sie wollen in deutschland urlaub machen
und da köln ein risikogebiet ist
brauchen sie einen negativen test
stichwort beherbergungs verbot reisen in
deutschland ist kompliziert geworden
ich habe bei der stadt können angerufen
und habe die info bekommen dass
ausschlag geben
die ergebniss mitteilung ist und
interesse habe ich im hotel angerufen
und dann hat man gesagt nein
ausschlaggebend ist der takt des
abstrichs ich wünsche dass das im lassen
testen so und so müssen etwas sache ist
aber wenn ich gesund bin dann bringe ich
auch reisen mehr tests wegen des
beherbergungs verbots zusätzlicher
stress für die gesundheitsämter die
ohnehin immer mehr probleme haben
kontaktpersonen von infizierten
ausfindig zu machen
was aber wichtig ist um infektionskette
zu unterbrechen
deswegen hilft jetzt auch die bundeswehr
bei der kontakt verfolgung die
kolleginnen und kollegen arbeiten ja
schon seit wochen und monaten am
anschlag
und das ist natürlich jetzt auch akut
ein großes problem
anders dagegen die situation in
deutschen krankenhäusern wie hier in
regensburg ist die lage noch entspannt
wenig corona patienten viele leere
intensivbetten und trotzdem gibt es ein
problem
wir müssen jetzt deutlich mehr wird das
personal sprechen
das war ein kraftakt für alle die
medizinischen bereich tätig waren das im
frühjahr tatsächlich zu leisten
aber das ist nicht beliebig wiederholbar
und das sehen auch viele pflegekräfte
sowie in regensburg heute auf die straße
gegangen sind um auf ihre schwierige
situation aufmerksam zu machen
der korona gipfel im kanzleramt dazu
sehen sie direkt im anschluss ein zdf
spezial alles zu der neuen maßnahmen
finden sie wie immer aktuell online auf
heute de und in der zdf- heute- app die
korona pandemie trifft die deutsche
wirtschaft härte als noch im frühjahr
angenommen
die führenden
wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute
revidieren in ihrem herbstgutachten ihre
prognose für dieses und nächstes jahr um
jeweils gut einen prozentpunkt nach
unten
für das laufende jahr gehen sie jetzt
von einem minus von 5,4 prozent aus und
für 2021 rechnen sie nur noch mit einem
wachstum von 4,7 prozent in den
niederlanden mussten angesichts
drastisch steigender infektionszahlen
vorübergehend einige notaufnahmen
schließen
betroffen waren krankenhäuser in
amsterdam rotterdam und den haag
ab heute gelten neue regeln bars und
restaurant müssen zu machen der verkauf
von alkohol ist ab 20 uhr untersagt in
allen öffentlichen räumen gilt außerdem
eine masken pflicht und neben corona
nähert sich ja auch die grippesaison
zwei krankheiten und eine doppelte
herausforderung für das
gesundheitssystem 26 millionen impfdosen
gegen die grippe stünden zur verfügung
trotzdem werden sie in manchen
arztpraxen knapp das sei aber nur
vorübergehend so versichert
gesundheitsminister sparen
einen versorgungsengpass werde es nicht
geben
mit gutem beispiel vorangehen
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen bei
seiner grippe schutzimpfung verbunden
mit dem appell dass sich vor allem
menschen ab 60 jahren und risikogruppen
impfen lassen sollten lieber kleine
pieks bedeutet dreifach in schutz
beschützt mich als wie ängsten vor der
grippe schützt andere in meinem umfeld
davor sich anzustecken und er schützt
das gesundheitssystem vor überlastung
rund 14 millionen menschen ließen sich
im vergangenen jahr impfen für diese
grippe saison wurden in deutschland 26
millionen impfdosen gekauft fast doppelt
so viele wie vergangenes jahr verbraucht
wurden wegen der korona pandemie und dem
risiko einer doppel ansteckung ist die
grippeschutzimpfung schafft in diesem
jahr aber auch größer im augenblick
scheint ein engpass da zu sein aber es
werden in den nächsten wochen noch sehr
viele impfstoffe auf den markt kommen
fünf millionen sind im augenblick in der
auslieferung und 6 millionen werden noch
vom bundesministerium für gesundheit auf
den markt gebracht ob das reicht ist die
frage apotheker germeshausen hat noch
impfstoff doch es gibt derzeit auch
engpässe in einigen apotheken und
arztpraxen das ein ganz natürliches
phänomen das wir seit jahren erleben
dass am anfang der impfsaison aufregung
darüber herrscht wie die regionale
verteilung ist das sind anfängliche
verteilungsprobleme die da sind die sich
relativ schnell ausgleichen danach ist
eigentlich dafür gesorgt dass genügend
impfstoff da ist eine schlussfolgerung
aus den jahrelangen erfahrungen von
fachleuten ob sie unter corona pany
die bedingungen richtig liegen dass
diese experten weiter für eine breite
grippeschutz impfung werben zeigt dass
sie keinen engpass befürchten weniger
giftige chemikalien in unserem alltag
das ist das ziel der eu kommission heute
hat sie ihre pläne vorgestellt
es geht unter anderem um per und
polychlorierte acryl substanzen kurtz
gfs sie sind in vielen
alltagsgegenständen wie beschichtete
pfannen outdoor-jacken feuer löschen
oder kaffeebecher gelangen sie in den
körper schwächen sie unter anderem das
immunsystem in hohen dosen können sie
krebserregend sein
gunnar krüger berichtet altötting ist
bilderbuch bayern unsichtbar ist per
flur oktan säure die giftige chemikalie
die über das trinkwasser ins blut gerät
auch in das von edmund pichler
also haben praktisch jahrzehntelang
dieses wasser getrunken hat man
festgestellt also männer frauen mir dass
etwa 43 mikrogramm pva im blut und das
ist viel zu hoch was beweise europas
strenge chemie gesetze haben lücken
selbst die eu-kommission sieht das so
und will sie schließen künftig will sie
ganze stoffgruppen untersuchen und
einstufen im beispiel also alle pfs
diese einstufung gilt dann für an der
derzeit 40 gesetze die chemikalien
betreffen unverzichtbare anwendungen
bleiben erlaubt andere werden verboten
ins projekte statt zu reagieren wollen
wir vorbeugend wir verbieten den einsatz
der schädlichsten stoffe in
verbraucherprodukten
dem vorschlag müssen die
mitgliedsstaaten noch zustimmen doch die
ziehen so der vorwurf aus parlament und
wirtschaft die einstufung schädlicher
stoffe gern in die länge man schaut sich
dann an substanz xy wird in neben den
und den bereichen eingesetzt und dann
wird eine risikoabschätzung gemacht und
während dieser ganzen zeit bleibt das
zeug am markt völlig unbeschränkt wir
würden auch schnellere entscheidungen
begrüßen das schafft auch
rechtssicherheit für die unternehmen
wir müssen aber andererseits sehen dass
wir für solche entscheidungen
wissenschaftlichen risikobewertung
benötigen verbote und beschränkungen auf
zuruf das geht nicht
das wasserwerk von altötting brauchte
übrigens eine nachrüstung edmund pichler
meint das geld hätte man gespart hätte
man die chemikalie früher es gift
eingestuft
in knapp drei wochen ist wahl in den usa
in einigen bundesstaaten dürfen die
wählerinnen und wähler bereits jetzt an
die wahlurne
auch in georgia im süden der usa dort
berichtet ines trams wird besonders
deutlich wie republikaner versuchen die
schwarze minderheit daran zu hindern
ihre stimme abzugeben
mit campingstühlen kommen sie in der
nacht stunden bevor die wahllokale
aufmachen groß der andrang der wähler in
georgia doch es gibt probleme wieder
einmal wahlmaschinen funktionieren nicht
zu wenig wahllokale auf der
internetseite steht dass die wartezeit
am tag bei acht stunden liegt darum bin
ich heute einfach mal früh aufgestanden
schwarze machen über 30 prozent der
wähler in georgia aus eine wichtige
wählergruppe die er die demokraten wählt
das macht sie zur bedrohung für
republikaner die sie vom urnengang
abhalten wollen immer wieder werden in
schwarzen bezirken die anzahl der
wahllokale reduziert die auflagen
verschärft sich auszuweisen und die
briefwahl erschwert die rechtfertigung
der republikanischen landesregierung man
wolle wahlbetrug vorbeugen
tatsächlich dienen diese maßnahmen dazu
schwarze stimmen zu unterdrücken
der einzige weg für die konservativen zu
gewinnen ist zu betrügen
das new yorker project will
dagegenhalten mit massiver
wahlbeteiligung von schwarzen wollen sie
den effekt solcher tricks ausgleichen
sie schwärmen aus um so viele menschen
wie möglich als wähler zu registrieren
ich möchte das schwarze ihre macht
erkennen das ist doch der einzige grund
dass einige leute uns an der stimmabgabe
hindern wollen sie haben angst davor
viele menschen kommen diese woche zum
wählen in georgia das ist ein gutes omen
für die präsidentschaftswahl im november
beunruhigend dass ihnen das wählen
erneut nicht leicht gemacht wird
die usa vor der wahl auslandsjournal die
doku kampf um ein neues amerika läuft
heute nacht um 1 und bereits jetzt in
der mediathek eine reise zur raumstation
iss dauerte bisher rund sechs stunden
heute morgen ging es viel schneller nach
dem start in baikonur in kasachstan nahm
die sojus-rakete eine besonders kurze
flug bahn und nach nur gut drei stunden
hatten die drei raumfahrer innen nach
einem aufwändigen andockmanöver ihr ziel
schon erreicht
in 400 kilometern höhe voraussichtlich
bis zum frühjahr sollen die us
astronautin und zwei russische
kosmonauten auf der iss bleiben
ja und nun zu der sport und zum spiel
der deutschen nationalmannschaft gegen
die schweiz hätte das war ja das dritte
länderspiel der dfb elf in nur einer
woche
es gab nur einen glanzlosen sieg und
gestern abend das zweite unentschieden
vorne die ist ja eigentlich ganz gut
aber hinten da zeigte joachim löws
mannschaft deutliche schwächen aufs
kreuz gelegt haben die schweizer nicht
nur antonio rüdiger sondern die gesamte
deutsche abwehr und das nicht nur
sinnbildlich 0 zu 2 stand gestern abend
in köln schon mitte der ersten halbzeit
die viererkette der deutschen ist
derzeit nicht konkurrenz klar wir müssen
den einen oder anderen situation noch
ja besser verteidigen liga verteidigen
erwachsener verteidigen joachim löw sah
neben dem schatten hinten auf so manches
licht vorne sorgte erst timo werner für
den anschluss und dann sein
mannschaftskollege beim fc chelsea kein
herz für den ausgleich angreifen können
sie also schon ziemlich gut nur eben
verteidigen klar könne man insgesamt als
mannschaft noch besser müsse man da auch
natürlich in zukunft das optimieren
das highlight bescherte sabri diesem
fußballabend ohne zuschauer sein
ausgleich zum 3 3
kohl als einziges in erinnerung bleiben
und die tatsache dass löw noch viel
arbeit hat bis zur em im nächsten sommer
erfolgreicher dagegen am gestrigen abend
die deutsche u21 nationalmannschaft
wegen eines ebenfalls spektakuläre
hackentreffer in fürth gewann das team
gegen bosnien herzegowina knapp mit 1 0
torjäger lukas meyer brachte das
kunststück in der 29 minute fertig die
dfb elf ist damit der em-qualifikation
einen großen schritt näher gerückt
beim atp-tennisturnier in köln hatte
qualifikant oscar otto am montag die
deutsche nummer zwei jahren lennard
struff überraschend besiegt heute aber
musste sich der lokalmatador oben im
schwarzen trikot geschlagen geben der
27-jährige verlor im achtelfinale in
drei hart umkämpften sätzen gegen den
moldauer dual bot mit 14 6 7 zu 5 und 5
die spiele seit heute in köln ohne
publikum wegen der stark gestiegene
gewundert sein
das mittwochslotto muss auch ohne
publikum aus kommen hier sind die zahlen
sie lauten 6 14 20 25 26 27 und die
superzahl 2 weitere gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotter punkt zdf.de und im zdf
text auf seite 55 7 der sturm an der
ostsee flaut jetzt ab und morgen ist es
meist trüb und grau
genaueres gleich von katja fischer das
heute journal mit marietta slomka heute
erst gegen 22 uhr
wir sagen danke für ihr interesse
wünschen einen entspannten abend und
sagen tschüss bis morgen abend um 7
und hier geht es jetzt gleich weiter mit
unserem spezial zum corona gipfel im
kanzleramt heute
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren die
sturmflut hat die ostsee erreicht und
schon heute früh gab es hier in sellin
auf rügen sehr hohe wellen von der
ostsee ist das wirklich ungewöhnlich von
der nordsee kennen wir so hohe wellen
aber dahinter steckte eben ein ganz
besonderes tief nämlich das tief gisela
und das trieb eben mit nordostwind das
wasser der ostsee an die küste
dieses tief gisela ist inzwischen weiter
nach osten gezogen und für uns
interessant wird bald auch dass die
folge dass nämlich über frankreich liegt
es gab also heute schwere sturmböen am
kap arkona auf rügen und auch sonst war
sehr stürmisch an der ostsee und wir
fragen uns wie lange bleibt es noch so
stürmisch in der nacht schon noch vor
allen dingen an der ostküste rügens und
auf usedom aber bis morgen früh ist der
strom dann weg dafür regnet es heute
nacht noch zum teil kräftig besonders
hier in sachsen und die temperaturen
sinken auf werte zwischen 10 grad an der
ostsee und 0 grad am alpenrand und
morgen liegen sie dann meist um 10 grad
am kühlsten platz an den alpen bei 6
grad am mildesten wird es an oder und
neiße mit 12 grad
das wird ein trüber donnerstag ab und zu
fällt etwas regen im nordwesten sehen
sie auch mal die sonne
trüb und kühl geht es auch in den
nächsten tagen weiter schönen abend noch